freddie peralta looking for his first
win in the month of may his third start
in may ready talked about the no
decision against the cardinals seven
innings one hit
hide adrianza making his third
consecutive start braves are still
without ronald acuna it's peralta deals
it and pop-up
into right field
abby garcia
makes the play and that's how the day
begins for freddie peralta one away for
freddie freeman
and a swing out of this peralta strikes
him out change up
good pitch big movement by freddie
on that last changeup ozuna who has had
a decent series 2-2 on the way and it's
in the air left center
back on it is kane with room just enough
for him my goodness and limiting
opponents two or less has been the
specialty for brave starter wasskari
noah well they got their hands full
today in this third game of the series
lost guards last four starts 4-0 with a
111 era with a six walks 24k
back-to-back base hits out of narviage
and kane
[Applause]
the rears have a couple of it on base
with one down for travis shaw
swing and a miss 99 down away
not many hitters at this level or any
other are going to hit that pitch at two
strikeouts for a noah
garcia breaks his backgrounds to short
the peg to third they get the force
there and that will retire the side
freddie peralta who worked one two three
atlanta first inning will face ozzy
albies to leave things off in the second
and then a hitless first inning today is
alby sends one deep left center field
long run for bradley oh
how about it
jackie bradley jr
what a catch
always has to try somebody else
as good as the home run robbery was
this one
was better just for the ground he had to
cover look at this play
[Applause]
the plate with a chance to make it
one-nothing brewers
he stabbed that ball and strikes out so
we know it gets him up and away that's a
big second out his third strikeout and
how colton wong is coming up first and
third now two outs in the second they're
hitting with runners in scoring position
jeff has been abysmal
sharkly head
dansby two knees got unload quickly and
he did to get colton wong andy noah
works around the lead-off walk and a
pass ball to preserve a scoreless tie
after two it is freddie peralta going to
work against ender and ciarte working on
a play like that
peralta puts away ncrt just blew it
right by him
and now it's
noah coming to the plate oh and to the
count
got him yep just keep throwing him right
out there and i'm not going to hit that
out that's his fifth back to the top of
the order in array adrianza 2-2 pitch
fastball got him
96 mile an hour gas
and peralta strikes out the side his
last five outs of k's so back-to-back
base hits open up the third inning for
the thump
starting with travis shaw
strike three at 98 blister to corner
shaw is hitless in the series and
there's the first out brewers hitting in
the low
100s with runners in scoring position
during this three and ten stretch needs
one here two one on the ground swanson
gloves it and throws to third for the
out gets the force brewers had first and
second nobody out same situation now
with two outs
full count two outs kane and garcia will
take off
and volvo back right field hit well down
to the wall
kane will score
garcia will score
daniel vogelback a two rbi double there
you go
brewers up two nothing
finally something for the crowd to get
excited about a lead in the series for
the brewers
came off the bat at 107 miles an hour
coming in at 98 it was the same pitch he
had just taken for strike two fastball
down and in just out of the reach of
adrian's in right freeman holds to
colton wong omar
is two for two against e noah and
narvaya's right field hit well that is
gonna be at the base of the wall
wrong cranks it up he's gonna be sent
home
he's thrown to the plate long is it
second straight inning the brewers have
produced
runs with two outs
top spin line drive by narvaez it short
hop the wall and right kind of deadened
like a lob wedge
that allowed
colton long to score from first to throw
from albies was air mailed they sit for
travis shaw and avi garcia coming up he
was aboard and rode home on that two-run
double by vogelback in the third
garcia center field back on it
ncrt at the wall he leaps and
it is gone just
over the glove and out of here go ahead
travis and it's a two-run home run for
abby garcia he was close
but garcia will touch them all
the brewers
finally showing some signs of life
offensively good to see
five nothing milwaukee bases loaded and
the banner is avi garcia hit the two-run
home run back in the fifth ten in a row
and that gets by contreras in the score
as well
all three runners advance wong scores
run number six
straight balls who have never seen
anything like this before
three consecutive walks
and they're loaded up again got a chance
to turn a good day into a great day
right here if you're daniel vogelback
and he pulls one all these goes to
second out there that's all they'll get
that'll be an rbi for volvo back
and it is seven to nothing milwaukee
that brings up jackie bradley jr two men
are out now runners at the corners look
out that gets by contreras yeah and
coming in to score travis shaw the
brewers have eight on the board new
pitcher for the brewers is jp fire eisen
now they're loaded and ender and ciarte
coming up that one right back where it
came from it took his cap off
dansby's gonna score streaking around is
riley he's gonna score
contreras stops at second and ender with
a two run single and the braves
are down six oh and all of a sudden the
braves are seeing the baseball a lot
better and now they will take aim at
brent suiter who's the new brewers
pitcher
and the first one on the ground hits
slowly towards short they will go to
second ball dropped everybody's safe
atlanta's got him loaded and now it gets
interesting the top of the order is
coming up
sharply hit but too short
little shovel that ball is dropped
everybody's safe again holy smokes
they're gift wrapping this game for the
braves if they want to take it contreras
scores the third run and now freddie
freeman is coming up with the bases
loaded still one out so here's freddie
now
and he unloads on the very first pitch
deep center kane going back track wall
grand slam for freeman and you've got to
be kidding me oh boy have the tides
turned here in milwaukee
when brian snitker said we're starting
to look like ourselves a week ago or so
this is the kind of game he had in mind
this team last year two years before
never quit
down eight nothing atlanta's come back
with seven in the seven and now lorenzo
kane
hits with the bases full of brewers
here it comes
kane in the air left field down base
head in the scores
ureas
behind him he'll score lorenzo kane
delivers
it's a two-run single for lorenzo kane
make it 10-7 milwaukee brewers have been
looking for these big hits with runners
in scoring position all week long
they've got two big ones on the day and
just like that the braves bring the
tying run to the plate again this game
has turned ugly in the last couple of
innings and this is starting to look
like big trouble here for williams in
this eighth inning
on the ground that'll be bobbled the
throw to second dropped and everybody's
allows swanson to score it's a 10-8 game
ciarte drops a bunt down that's a beauty
going to be a tough play reyes though to
first oh my goodness what a play
whoa
pablo
reyes with a gem i didn't think he had a
chance no kidding devon williams against
one of the game's best players in acuna
what a matchup and brian snicker has
been waiting for a moment to use him and
he's got one and he got him
the airbender
struck him out with a change up now
adrianza williams a long pause he deals
in a swing and a miss he struck him out
back-to-back case with the change-up
it's a one-run game but the braves are
down to their last out down so here is
contreras
go ahead run aboard now for atlanta josh
hayder ready to fire and a
a miss swinging
ball game is over
the brewers win
a wipe of the brow kind of game today